let's bring in National border patrol
Council Vice President John anfinson
thank you John for talking to us um
first of all this is a humanitarian
crisis I mean there's no other way to
describe it and now with title 42
potentially ending tomorrow it's only
going to get worse the stream of illegal
immigrants will continue to flow in at
even larger numbers what are you feeling
with this potential end looming tomorrow
well it's frustrating because we've been
here before where title 42 was about to
go away and that Homeland Security
didn't really have a plan so now instead
of changing the policies to maybe deter
people from Crossing or seeking Asylum
and sort of abusing the process now
we're just worried about a logistics
issue they're just trying to get better
at processing more people in a faster
time frame completely sacrificing border
security
yeah I mean there were record border
number uh you know numbers released for
the month of November and and they were
quite staggering I mean in fact the
month of November had over 200 000
illegal immigrants Crossing into the
Border despite the cold weather the
Christmas weekend all of that
um but you know El Paso is now the U.S
epicenter of the Border crisis
um what would you say for El Paso what
are border officials they're expecting
ahead of title 42's end
well it's not even just El Paso every
sector at this point is bracing uh for
what's to come because every sector has
been expelling people under title 42. so
the thousands and thousands of people
that are getting expelled they're just
waiting until the Supreme Court makes a
decision and this is this could be
stopped tomorrow or the day after if
there was just a policy change they This
truly is a humanitarian crisis and now
we have people freezing on the streets
in El Paso just like we had people
drowning in the river in Eagle Pass
earlier this year the policies that are
in place they're basically creating a
situation where people are risking
everything to come here because they've
been given the green light to cross the
border and border patrol were left
trying to do our job but it's
practically impossible when we're stuck
indoors processing uh paperwork to send
people up for their Asylum interviews
when a reality the agents should be out
of the brush chasing the people that are
actively trying to get away from us
every single day
um that I want to talk about that Friday
night news dump because we just found
out these staggering numbers from the
month of November right and I'm just
wondering what youth make of this do you
think that the Biden Administration was
maybe possibly trying to keep these new
numbers under wraps as we await the end
of title 42.
it's possible I mean every month they
try to quietly sneak them out there so I
don't think this month was any different
but the numbers were the highest we've
seen and those numbers actually include
uh with the Customs officers are dealing
with as well just border patrol alone
had something like 207 or so eight 207
000 of those encounters were already on
track to beat that number just with
border patrol alone because I think
we're averaging something like 7 500 or
so encounters per day and yesterday we
had a brief reprieve it was a slow day
on the border with only a few maybe
three or four thousand that actually
crossed but every other day before that
had been over seven thousand or eight
thousand so you know this these numbers
I think the the White House is clearly
trying to not celebrate them but you
know this is what we're dealing with
they can't acknowledge what the reality
is at the border yeah I want to talk
about El Paso Airport what a nightmare I
you know the international airport and
also on the street feet there's video
actually of migrants being met by armed
Texas National Guard that's where these
you know these numbers have led us to uh
the latest numbers in El Paso the sector
numbers on Christmas weekend alone total
encounters 16 476. but this is the
number I want to point out here title 42
expulsions
2150. those are the expulsions that we
need but under this Administration that
number should be much higher so this
Administration hasn't been properly
enforcing title 42 which was working
under the Trump Administration what
would you like to see uh done
well I mean at this point title 42 is
going to have to go away at some point
whether it's tomorrow or six months from
now it doesn't really matter the problem
is that we don't have a replacement you
know we would go back to our Authority
that we normally have prior to the
pandemic which is to process people for
removal and that sort of thing but
ultimately if everybody's just going to
cross some request Asylum it doesn't
really matter uh what Authority we're
using if they're just going to be
released so even if uh title 42 were to
stick around for a little while we have
to make some kind of preparation for
what to do once it does go away and the
White House asking for a delay of six
days is sort of a joke because that
suggests that they had a plan that was
ready to go uh starting on the 27th we
all know that that's not the case so
we're all just sort of bracing we at
this point agents are kind of just like
we need to rip off the Band-Aid and just
deal with it because this is the only
way that we might get people to actually
acknowledge that there truly is a
problem at the border yeah or like
Lindsey Graham said I'm going to
rephrase it that Biden needs to get his
butt to the Border he didn't use the
word but but I think you know what I'm
talking about maybe the President should
actually visit the border for the first
time ever in his life perhaps in the new
year we'll see that maybe that could be
his New Year's resolution John uh thank
you so much anfinson for joining me
appreciate it
thanks for having me I'm Steve Ducey I'm
Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis